hello everyone in the comments section
of each of my previous videos i have
received multiple requests
uh from a number of students about
making a video targeted specifically at
mtech students so here it is i've made a
video i hope it will help you
now before we can jump into this pieces
of advices
advice that i'm going to share uh it is
important to understand that at the
empty level we are talking about more
senior students so at this senior level
there is a greater variety in the hopes
and aspirations of the various students
compared to the undergraduate level so
we have to first identify the
broadly the different kinds or groups of
students
along with the different hopes and
aspirations that they have
so as to put the
pieces of advice that i'm going to share
in the proper context
okay so the first group of students is
comprises
those who
have cleared gate
with the primary objective of
joining a psu
now
there is nothing wrong with that now
what happens is that
the scheduling of the psu interviews is
such that the
classes at the iits and nits they
already start so these students they
join the iits and nits and other various
proper institutes
but that is like a stopgap arrangement
their primary objective remains joining
the psus
i have no problem with that as i said
but
what i'm going to share the pieces of
advice it is not relevant for them
the second group of students are those
who have cleared gate who want to
complete their empty degree from the
iits the nits the different good
institutes
but it is
perhaps only with the sole intention of
getting the tank of that good institute
so that it will help them in their
placements uh down the line
i mean at the end of the two-year degree
course
now i'm not trying to be judgmental here
because i am very much aware of the
practical realities of a middle class
family from which
many of these students belong
and the need of getting a job
but this is where i mean this kind of
aspiration is where most of the
conflicts arise between what the
students expect and what is the reality
okay there's a big big conflict here and
it is
targeted to this group of students that
i wish to
aim my pieces of advice the third group
of students
comprises those who
have cleared gate
and have joined the iits the 90s and
various institutes but they genuinely
have a wish to complete their mtech
degree properly to learn something
properly
maybe
down the line they also wish to go for
jobs uh maybe for higher studies
but they have a genuine wish to put in
the work required
but even then
there is a subgroup of students among
them
who
suffer from certain misconceptions and i
hope my pieces of advice will be
helpful to them also
so let's now jump into the actual pieces
of advice so first of all regarding the
course work uh please note that in this
video i'm not going to discuss anything
about the research work which takes
place in the second year of their
studies
uh
maybe a dedicated video for that for the
research work needs to be made
separately uh this is only uh about the
course work and other such stuff so
regarding course work there is often a
massive conflict in the minds of the
students
so what happens is that sometimes
they are stuck uh thinking
or or keeping their level at the
undergraduate or maybe at the level of
the gate preparation
okay so this is where the biggest
conflict is because you understand that
uh most of these mtech level courses
at the iits and i'm sure at the nits
they are designed in such a fashion that
they are supposed to act as a bridge
between
the introductory undergraduate level
courses on the one hand and the higher
level research kind of studies which is
required okay at the at the higher
studies level okay so the empty level
courses are like a bridge between them
so
what actually happens in reality is that
in these courses sometimes
you
don't just need to learn new stuff
rather you also have to imbibe or
learn completely afresh new ways of
thinking
sometimes what happens that over the
course of half a semester even one
semester
students have to learn an entirely new
framework
so unless the students are
very much open-minded or receptive to
these new ways or new needs of learning
this are often left with a feeling of
extreme frustration
and this frustration stems from the fact
that
in their head they keep thinking that
the coursework will still be nicely
chopped up into little chapters with
problem sets at the end
uh and when this does not happen like it
used to happen in their undergraduate
days
they are i mean left feeling
and what is happening why why why are
these things why are these unfamiliar
things happening to me
so a very important point to note is
that you are supposed to feel a little
bit uncomfortable okay so if you are
actually feeling uncomfortable with
these courses embrace that feeling okay
because the point of mtech is not to
help you
or not to cram new stuff into your brain
which perhaps we did not have the time
uh
in the undergraduate days that is not
the point at all
okay so you have to understand
why the term master okay master of
technology
what is the significance of this word
master
the real meaning is that
a master is not someone
who is supposed to be aware of all the
formula or perhaps even all the
derivations rather a true master is one
who
has developed
an ability to learn the things
which he doesn't know
even more importantly he has developed
an ability to identify the things which
he doesn't know to diagnose his own
shortcomings and to address them on his
own that is the true mark of a master
and the whole point of this course work
and various curricula
as part of this master's level courses
this is designed to help you and to push
you actually even even if it means means
making you a little bit uncomfortable it
is to push you towards the direction of
achieving that level of mastery okay so
that has to be remembered very very
importantly
next uh
as part of the coursework sometimes here
in
the iits certainly in iit khep we have
the system of seminars okay so i'm not
talking about the research level
seminars which you have to do in your
second year rather i'm talking about the
first year seminars as part of the
coursework so this is like some kind of
net practice to help you prepare for the
next year
but this is actually a great opportunity
not just to develop the soft skills like
presentation public speaking
actually making the presentation itself
all these things for the sake of your
second year research preparation rather
it can actually help you towards
preparing yourself uh for
uh
for jobs for actual uh for the actual
soft skills which are required uh in in
industry okay so many students do not
take full uh uh to not take full
advantage of these seminars i've seen
this so please please try to be a little
bit aware about this
the next piece of advice that i would
like to share is
something very niche and very close to
my heart
is that i've often seen that many of the
mtx students they do not take full uh
advantage of the wonderful library
facilities which are there in the iit's
and i'm sure
the internet is also a very good
libraries so please please make it a
point to
i mean i know
you have been suffering from this online
semester but uh
at some point you will get to come to
the
campus and
you will get to visit the library so do
visit the library up i mean
many uh so-called modern people will say
that what is the point of a library
everything is now available digitally
you can download books at your own free
will but
i mean the feeling of a library is
completely different okay you have to
visit it to really understand and please
note that fine you can download books
but you have to know which books to
download so library is a great place not
only for you to find books that you are
looking for but also to explore the
other kinds of books which you may not
be aware of
okay so it's it's actually a great place
for exploration and uh and or the
exposition of your mind
so take advantage of it
the next advice that i would like to
give is regarding the interaction that
you could have
or that you should have with the
undergraduate students
okay so this is
a kind of a sensitive issue
because uh there is some kind of
i mean
i would not say conflict but
some kind of
different feelings associated uh with
the
potential interactions between
undergraduate students and postgraduate
students
some of which is not at all desirable
okay i'm sure you know what i'm talking
about
so
try to get beyond these feelings
okay
and try to rise above those things
because
i can understand that as mtech students
you are
at least a year senior to the
undergraduate students so suppose we are
talking about fourth year students uh
and maybe even fifth students i mean at
best you are i mean same as them or in
all likelihood you are you are senior to
them in age so maybe it feels a little
bit awkward for you to take
advice or maybe interact with them
but do understand that within the iit
system or maybe within the nit system
in terms of experiences within the
campus they are senior to you okay maybe
they are younger to you in age but they
are senior to you in terms of the the
iit experience of the night experience
okay so they do have some very valuable
experiences to share they have some
valuable pieces of advice that they can
potentially give you
try to take advantage of that by trying
to mix freely with them okay initially
they you need to maybe make some
proactive effort to break the ice uh but
i can assure you this much that the
students who are genuinely academically
serious among the undergraduate
community they will never have uh
any kind of uh
deep
ill feeling towards you
which brings me to the next point and
this is perhaps the most important point
which i would like to emphasize on
see i have often seen that the mtx
students when they come to the campus
they suffer from almost like a sub
surface feeling of
inferiority
okay
so i've said it out loud
i know it is there
but they should not be there
okay this feeling of infinity i'm sure
it stems from the fact that when you
look around yourself you see the
undergraduate students it always reminds
you of the fact that maybe you were not
successful enjoy and these are the
students who
who are successful and this feeling is
perhaps a little bit more stark when you
see the fourth year of the fifth year
students because they are closer to you
in your age
so
remember this okay you have passed gate
gate is not an easy exam to pass
for instance
you just take the gate question paper
and give it to any arbitrary like not
arbitrary you give it to a good
undergraduate student
do you think you will be able to get 98
99 percentile without any preparation
so you have done the preparation you
have proved yourself that you are good
in your undergraduate studies
okay
so be a little bit proud of that fact
okay so if you if you if you feel like
that if you develop that feeling i'm
sure
you'll you will uh easily overcome your
feeling of infinite it will actually
give you some pride and
it will help you to interact better with
the with the undergraduate students
and it can make your stay at the iits at
the and the night is much more enriching
okay because you get to share so much
experiences with them and i can assure
you they also have a lot to learn from
you
okay so if any undergraduate student is
actually watching this up to this part
of the video
please please make it a point to mix
freely with the mtx students you have a
lot to learn from them i'm telling this
from my first hand experience one of my
best friends
during my dual degree days my fourth and
fifth year was
an empty student only and he's still my
good friend
okay finally uh one piece of advice is
that
you see there is no shying away from the
fact that you have to put in the work
okay you can't simply coast along you
have to put in the work there are lots
and lots of opportunities at the iit's
at the united s
to
actually level up
make full use of those opportunities
actually level up
okay so maybe you are a little bit weak
in speaking english
get a group of friends around you
practice it in a very proactive fashion
maybe you wish to uh get some skills in
programming there are many undergraduate
students who are who have already
leveled up in that aspect interact with
them get some help uh get some tips from
them
level up yourself okay so
if you actually put in the effort
in these various aspects the coursework
the way that i put it uh
the
the various extracurricular things
various interactions various seminars if
you have gone through all these
processes like soaking in all the
opportunities to the best possible
extent then at the end of the day
when it comes for the time of placement
you will see that the recruiters who are
actually experienced engaging your inner
qualities and actually seeing through
you they will be able to pick that yes
there is some genuine quality in this
student and they will pick you okay
so
uh so peop so the irony is that people
who just keep on thinking about
placement and not put the work they
coast along they will be at a far worse
situation at the time of placement
compared to students who come to iit or
nit and soak in the experience
take full advantage of all the
opportunities and
and prepare themselves really really in
a genuine fashion well okay so
uh all the very best to you uh in your
preparation in your stay at these
institutes uh that you have
managed to come
through your uh
by clearly by creating gate
and
i wish that you have a wonderful carrier
thank you very much